Like all of our other equations, we can check to make sure that this solution
is correct. If we substitute in positive root 6 into our equation, we'll notice
that it checks. The square root of 6 squared equals 6, and 5 times 6 equals 30.
But remember, we can have the positive answer or the negative answer. So let's
check x equal to negative root 6. We plug in negative root 6 in for x, and
square it. Squaring a negative number always results in a positive. So we know
negative root 6 squared equals positive 6. Then we have 5 times 6, which is 30,
so our answer checks. This is always a great way to check your answers. ANd
this reinforces why we have the plus or minus symbol. It's because we have two
answers.